Prince William pays tribute to the  victims of the Manchester bombing the 34  year old royal laid a wreath at Wembley  Stadium on Saturday ahead of the FA Cup  Finals in honor of the 22 victims who  died and 59 that were injured in last  week's tragic bombing outside of ariana  grande's concert in Manchester England  Kensington Palace posted at this photo  of William holding his wreath revealing  the Duke of Cambridge's message attached  read we will never fear coming together  to celebrate all that unites us in  memory of the friends and family taken  from us in Manchester meanwhile at  Kensington Palace Williams brother  Prince Harry spent some time with former  US President Barack Obama the pair posed  together while discussing a wide range  of political topics including the  devastating terror attack  you